hey 42 here Google and Yahoo both use
goats to trim their lawns welcome to RIF
there are more stretch limos in Glasgow
than in Los Angeles new research shows
that for luxury brands such as expensive
perfumes and close the ruder the sales
staff are the higher the sales in 2013
police in the Maldives arrested a
coconut on suspicion of vote rigging
without BAPS
tequila would not exist it's made from
the agave plant which is pollinated by
BATS
there are 20 million sea containers in
the world
the ship's crews have no idea what's in
them being lonely is as bad for your
health as smoking 15 cigarettes a day
the Aztecs wore necklaces made a popcorn
boys in Bronze Age Russia had to slay
their own dogs to prove that they were
ready to become warriors charitable
donations of clothing to Africa has
actually led to the collapse of its
textile industry a quarter of all the
vegetables eaten in the US are french
fries the phrase pipe dream originates
from the fantasies that one experiences
when smoking opium a study in
Switzerland revealed that stockbrokers
are more reckless and more manipulative
than diagnosed Psychopaths Stalin hated
his own son so much that when he tried
to commit suicide by shooting himself
Stalin only commented he can't even
shoot straight the mortality rate of pop
stars is 1.7 times higher than average
misspell is one of the most commonly
misspelled words in the English language
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you